what's the deal with tickling
are all vertebrates ticklish why can't i
tickle myself
yeah um no most vertebrates are not
checklish in fact most
mammals are not ticklish there are a few
examples
if i'm recalling correctly irritable you
can irritate them
but you can irritate any vertebrae
that's almost certain
but in terms of ticklishness what is it
is it
i'm tempted to say there's a prosimian
that
i've seen compelling so that's not a
that's not a clade anymore
uh no it's not a clade because of
tarsiers having been
anyway um but anyway non-monkey
primates right like uh it's not lemurs
but yes lemurs is english babies
gloggos yeah i think it might be
yeah glucose no no you're thinking
calugo you've got your galagos and your
colugas mixed up i do
both which are cute mammals yes um yeah
but anyway yes there are a few examples
of ticklish uh
mammals well i think um i think all the
great apes are
all the greatest apes well i think i
think
i think for sure we know chimps and
bonobos i think coco
the basically domesticated gorilla was
understood to be ticklish
i don't know about orangs i don't know
you you wouldn't want to test it on an
unsuspecting orange no but you could
maybe
you know convince a postdoc to
to test it um
all right i had to um okay so let's get
to the heart of the matter though
so i do have a hypothesis i don't know
if i've deployed this hypothesis on dark
course or
not on you didn't you do maybe you did
tickling you too a little
video i don't remember um anyway so here
i'll give you the short version um
the thing about their conspicuous
features of tickling you can't tickle
yourself
um nobody can walk up to you on a
battlefield and
tickle you and cause you to drop your
weapon
you're hard to tickle in water
so anyway my point is going to be
tickling requires
or ticklishness requires the
prerequisite is
a feeling of security so the hypothesis
is that tickling is a
built-in trainer for effectively
hand-to-hand combat and that the idea
is that there are places where you're
very vulnerable
and that this mechanism oh so there are
lots of other features that belong on a
list of
uh first of all where are you ticklish
that's an interesting list of places
right you take
on your neck ticklish under your arm
you're taking it from the bottom of your
feet
back your knees back your knees and
these are all places that if an enemy
gets to
you screwed up right so
the point and and then there's the
reaction of children to being tickled
right children like being sick they like
the tickle game
right they it's very easy to go too far
if you are you know tickling a child
who's playing
the tickle game with you and you keep
tickling them in the same place over and
over again
they can get very upset right so anyway
my point is this is a built-in training
program
for learning to protect vulnerable
places right and so the idea of hey i
want to play the tickle game
is like yeah i want to practice uh that
thing so i can protect myself later
right so you learn to protect yourself
being tickled in one spot ex for an
extended period of time
isn't productive because you're not
learning anything new about how to
protect that spot you've already
lost control of it the positive feedback
of
um well if you get somebody you know if
you
manage to get your finger under their
armpit they become [ __ ] and they have
a hard time
protecting themselves that's useful too
because the point is it
ups the ante for preventing somebody
from accessing you in the first place
rather than just fending them off once
they've gotten to you
but anyway the long short of it is it's
a built-in program
for trusted individuals to train each
other
into protecting uh against uh
hostile enemies later and that that
explains
all of these odd symptoms of
ticklishness that it requires trust
that you both do and don't want to be
tickled
that you you know all of all of the
features we just discussed
good um oh so and the prediction
gotta have a prediction sure right the
prediction would be
that um those who have engaged in
uh being tickled and learning to prevent
it
as youth would be better in a better
position to protect themselves they
would be more effective
at fending off a hostile hand-to-hand
combat
that's one prediction
you